أعلم أنك قد حددت بالفعل بعض
جوانب ما يوصف
بعقيدة بايدن الناشئة ، ما هي أكبر
الاختلافات من وجهة نظرك
بين مذهب ترامب وبايدن
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسياسة الخارجية.
معكم اليوم ،
شكرًا لاستضافتي
لإلقاء نظرة على ما أعتقد عندما ينظر الرئيس
إلى هذا الاستنتاجين الأساسيين
أه أولاً ، لا ينظم العالم
نفسه ، لذا إذا لم نكن
هناك ونقدم كل يوم نحاول
القيام ببعض من تلك المساعدة التنظيمية
لكتابة القواعد
وتشكيل القواعد التي تحكم
طريقة تعامل البلدان مع بعضها البعض ،
فإما أن يقوم شخص آخر
بذلك بدلاً منا أو ربما يفعل ذلك بنفس القدر الذي
لا يفعله أحد ، ومن ثم يكون لديك فوضى في
كلتا الحالتين ليست جيدة لـ  أمريكا ، لذا
الجزء الأول هو
المشاركة في المشاركة ، الجزء الثاني هو أن هذه
ليست واحدة من المشاكل الكبيرة التي
نواجهها والتي ستؤثر
في الواقع على حياة الشعب الأمريكي كل
يوم  إنها مناخ سواء كان
وباءً سواء كان انتشار أسلحة سيئة ،
فلا يمكن لأي
دولة أن تتصرف بمفردها حتى لو كانت
قوية مثل الولايات المتحدة ، لذلك
هناك علاوة على
التعاون وبالتالي علاوة على الدبلوماسية لأن
كيف تفعل ذلك؟  نحصل على هذا التعاون من
دول أخرى
، يبدأ بدبلوماسيتنا ، فلنتحدث
عن بعض القضايا المحددة
لروسيا ، يحذر الرئيس الأول بايدن من
أنه لن
يتردد في كلماته في رفع التكلفة
على روسيا ، لكن
إدارة بايدن لم تقدم أي شيء حتى الآن
تحديدًا ، ما تكلفة ذلك
من وجهة نظرك يبدو جيدًا
أولاً ، أعتقد أنه عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالسيد نافالني ،
فإن حقيقة أن روسيا تشعر بأنها مضطرة
لأن يشعر السيد بوتين بأنه مضطر لمحاولة
إسكات صوت واحد
يتحدث كثيرًا عن مدى أهمية
هذا
الصوت وكيف يكون  ممثل
لملايين الروس الذين يريدون أن
يُسمع صوتهم
والذين ضاقوا ذرعاً بالفساد
مع نظام الكليبتوقراطية ،
لكن ما نفعله هو أولاً  من بين جميع
الاستشارات والعمل عن كثب
مع الدول الأخرى التي
تشعر بالقلق الشديد بشأن ما حدث
ليس فقط للسيد البحرية ولكن الآخرين
الذين وقفوا لممارسة حقوقهم
ولكن ثانيًا آه الذئب كما تعلم أه
يبدو من الواضح أنه
تم استخدام سلاح كيميائي
حاول قتل السيد البحرية الذي ينتهك
اتفاقية الأسلحة الكيميائية
والتزامات أخرى لروسيا أنها
تنتهك
أه العقوبات الواضحة التي قام الكونجرس
بمراجعة ذلك أه نحن ننظر في
ذلك بعناية
شديدة وعندما نحصل على النتائج سوف نتخذ
إجراء  أه بالطريقة المناسبة
وبعد ذلك ستوضحها في ذلك
الوقت هل الاحتجاجات المؤيدة
لزعيم المعارضة
أليكسي نافالني من وجهة نظرك
تشير إلى ضعف
في بوتين عندما يتعلق الأمر بقبضة بوتين
على الدولة
أعتقد أنها تثير استياء عميقًا
أه
مع كما قلت الفساد الذي أه
المستشري حكم اللصوص
الذي أه أه يهيمن أه أه
الحكومة
أه وهو يتحدث فقط عن حقيقة
أنك  يبحث الروس
عن طرق للتأكد من أن
صوتهم مسموع وأن النظام كما هو
حاليًا لا يؤيد ذلك بالضبط ،
لذا انظروا إلى أن هذا
يتعلق أساسًا بروسيا
والشعب الروسي أه مستقبلهم
لا يتعلق بنا
وأعتقد أن الحكومة الروسية
سترتكب خطأً
في إسنادها إلى جهات خارجية سواء
كانت الولايات المتحدة
أه الشركاء الأوروبيون والآخرون
مسؤولية ما يحدث
هذا يتعلق أساسًا بروسيا
بشأن مستقبل روسيا ونأمل أن
يمضي نظام أكثر ديمقراطية إلى الأمام.
يواجه مأزقًا على
ما يبدو عندما يتعلق الأمر بإيران ،
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني ،
يقول آية الله الإيراني ، إننا بحاجة إلى رفع العقوبات
قبل أن
تعود إلى الاتفاق ، يقول الرئيس بايدن
إنه لن يرفع العقوبات أولاً ،
لذا فإن ما يحدث الآن يبدو جيدًا أن
الرئيس كان واضحًا جدًا بشأنه  هذا
لو عادت إيران أه للامتثال
لالتزاماتها بموجب الاتفاق النووي
أه سنفعل نفس الشيء و  ثم
سنعمل مع حلفائنا
وشركائنا لمحاولة بناء اتفاقية أطول
وأقوى وأيضًا
جلب بعض هذه القضايا الأخرى مثل
برنامج الصواريخ الإيراني مثل
إجراءاتها المزعزعة للاستقرار
في المنطقة والتي تحتاج إلى معالجة
وكذلك المشكلة التي نواجهها الآن  وولف هو أنه في
الأشهر الأخيرة
رفعت إيران قيدًا تلو
الآخر كانا موقوفين
باتفاق خرجنا من
الاتفاق
أه بدأت إيران في رفع القيود المختلفة
في
الاتفاق والنتيجة أنهم أقرب أه
من  لقد
كان لديهم القدرة في وقت قصير على
إنتاج مواد الواجهة لسلاح نووي ،
كانت الاتفاقية قد دفعت ذلك
العام الماضي وفقًا للتقارير العامة الآن ،
فقد انخفض الآن إلى
ثلاثة أو أربعة أشهر ويسير في
الاتجاه الخاطئ ،
لذا أه أول شيء  هذا أمر بالغ الأهمية
أن تعود إيران
للامتثال لالتزاماتها
أه هم بعيدون عن ذلك ولكن إذا
فعلوا ذلك أه فإن طريق الدبلوماسية
هناك  د نحن على استعداد للمضي قدمًا في ذلك حتى يتعين
عليهم اتخاذ الخطوة الأولى ، وبعد
ذلك سنرد
على ذلك وهو أن الرئيس
كان واضحًا بشأن حاجتهم
للعودة إلى الامتثال وإذا فعلوا ذلك
فسوف نتطلع إلى القيام بذلك  نفس الشيء ، دعنا
نتطرق إلى بعض القضايا الحساسة الأخرى ،
الرئيس بايدن هو إنهاء الدعم العسكري لنا
للعمليات الهجومية السعودية والإماراتية
في اليمن ، وإيقاف
مبيعات الأسلحة إلى تلك البلدان
مؤقتًا ، هل ينوي الرئيس بايدن
تغيير
العلاقة الأمريكية السعودية بشكل جيد أولاً في اليمن
نفسها.
حرج أه واحد
أه ننهي دعمنا لأه
الحملة العسكرية
بقيادة السعودية في اليمن
ثانياً كما نفعل نحن أيضاً
ملتزمون بشدة بالدفاع عن
عدوان السعودية
الموجه لها من الحوثيين أه كذلك
هاتان النقطتان
مهمتان للغاية النقطة الثالثة على الرغم من
أنها مهمة بنفس القدر حتى مع
خروجنا من دعم أه
الحملة العسكرية
التي نميل إلى اللعب فيها.  دور قيادي
في دور فاعل في الدبلوماسية
لمحاولة إنهاء الحرب فعلاً أه
الرئيس
أه من خلال وزارة الخارجية
عين مبعوثاً خاصاً رفيع المستوى
للتعامل مع أه اليمن وهو الآن
منخرط ويتصرف ونحتاج إلى الانكفاء
على هذا  هي
حسب معظم الروايات أسوأ أزمة إنسانية
في العالم وهذا يقول شيئًا
ما الآن أه ملايين الأشخاص
الذين يعيشون في وضع يائس للغاية
إنهاء الحرب
هو الشيء الحاسم
لتحسين أوضاعهم في وضعهم
وهذا بالتأكيد وضع فظيع
وزارة الخارجية ، أعطى المتحدث الرسمي
الفضل للإدارة الرابحة
لما يسمى باتفاق أبراهام
بصفقات التطبيع التي
أبرمتها إسرائيل
بفضل الإدارة الرابحة
مع الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، والبحرين ،
والسودان ، والمغرب ، ولكن في نفس الوقت
تقول
إنه لا يمكن أن يكون بديلاً.  من أجل
السلام الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ، فكيف ستعمل بالضبط على
إحياء عملية السلام الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية
بشكل جيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء نعم
صفقنا لاتفاقات إبراهيم أه
هذه خطوة مهمة إلى الأمام أه
كلما أه رأينا إسرائيل وأه جيرانها
أه تطبيع أه العلاقات يحسن
العلاقات
وهذا جيد لإسرائيل إنه جيد
للدول الأخرى المعنية
إنه جيد للسلم والأمن العام
وأعتقد  إنها تقدم آفاقًا جديدة
أه للناس في جميع أنحاء المنطقة من
خلال السفر عبر التجارة
أه من خلال أعمال أخرى أه
يمكنهم القيام بها معًا أه
لتحسين حياتهم
فعليًا وهذا شيء جيد ولكن كما قلت
بحق
أه هذا لا يعني  أن أه
تحديات أه العلاقة
بين إسرائيل والفلسطينيين تذهب
بعيدًا
هم لا أه لا يزالون هناك
لن يختفوا بأعجوبة
أه ولذا نحن أه نحن بحاجة إلى الانخراط في
ذلك ولكن في المقام الأول
أه  الأطراف المعنية بحاجة إلى
الانخراط في تلك النظرة
أه الحقيقة الصعبة هي أننا ما زلنا
بعيدين عن
رؤية أه السلام يندلع ورؤية
القرار النهائي  المشاكل بين أه
إسرائيل والفلسطينيين
وإنشاء
أم دولة فلسطينية في المقام الأول
الآن لا ضير نحن نتطلع
للتأكد من عدم اتخاذ أي من الطرفين
إجراءات أحادية الجانب تجعل
احتمالات التحرك نحو السلام
وحل متساوٍ.  أكثر تحديًا
مما هم عليه بالفعل
ومن ثم آمل أن نرى كلا
الجانبين يتخذان خطوات تخلق بيئة أفضل
يمكن أن تجري فيها مفاوضات فعلية
وأنا أعلم أنك أه ما
زالت إدارة بايدن تدعم ما يسمى
حل الدولتين ، إسرائيل وجديدة  دولة فلسطين
أه لكني أفهم أن الرئيس
بايدن لم يتحدث حتى بعد
أه مع رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ، صحيح
أنهم تحدثوا بالفعل خلال أه
أثناء الانتقال أعتقد أن إحدى أولى
المكالمات التي أجراها الرئيس كانت
مع  رئيس الوزراء لقد تحدثت مع
نظرائي الإسرائيليين أه في مناسبات متعددة
بالفعل وأنت محق تمامًا في
حل الدولتين أه ع  المقيم
يؤيدها بشدة إنها الطريقة الوحيدة
أه لضمان مستقبل إسرائيل كدولة يهودية
وديمقراطية
والطريقة الوحيدة لمنح
الفلسطينيين الدولة التي
يحق لهم الحصول عليها ولكن هل هناك سبب
كرئيس لم يتحدث
معه حتى الآن  نتنياهو لقد تحدث مع العديد
من قادة العالم الآخرين ، أنا متأكد من أنه
سيكون لديهم فرصة للتحدث
آه كما تعلمون في المستقبل القريب
متشوقون للحصول على
نعم أو لا في بعض
القضايا المحددة الحساسة للغاية التي قلتها
ستحتفظ
الدول بالسفارة الأمريكية في القدس التي اعتادت أن
تكون في تل أبيب ، هل تعتبر القدس
عاصمة لإسرائيل أه أفعل نعم
والأهم من ذلك أننا نقوم به
كجزء من اتفاقية إسرائيلية فلسطينية ،
هل
ستدعم فلسطين عاصمتها  في القدس الشرقية
انظروا ما يجب أن نراه يحدث هو
أه أن يلتقي الطرفان
أه مباشرة ويتفاوضان حول
ما يسمى
بقضايا الوضع النهائي
هذا هو الهدف وكما قلت نحن
للأسف طرق  بعيدًا عن ذلك في
هذه المرحلة من الزمن
، اعترفت الإدارة الرابحة كما تعلمون
أيضًا بالسيادة الإسرائيلية
على مرتفعات الجولان التي
استولت عليها إسرائيل من سوريا في عام 1967
أه
ستواصل إدارتكم إدارة بيدن النظر إلى
مرتفعات الجولان كجزء من
نظرة إسرائيل تتجاهل  شرعيات
ذلك أه هذا السؤال
من الناحية العملية أه
أه الهدف فيه مهم جدًا
لأمن أه إسرائيل طالما الأسد في
السلطة في سوريا
طالما أن إيران موجودة
في ميليشيات سورية مدعومة من إيران
أه أه  نظام الأسد نفسه كل
هذه تشكل
تهديدًا أمنيًا كبيرًا أه
لإسرائيل أه ومن الناحية العملية
أه السيطرة على أه الجولان في
هذا الوضع أه
أعتقد أنه يبقى ذو أهمية حقيقية
لأمن إسرائيل
أه الأسئلة القانونية شيء آخر
و  بمرور الوقت إذا
تغير الوضع في سوريا أه هذا
شيء ننظر إليه ولكننا لسنا
قريبين من ذلك